I think music is probably a better
metaphor at least for Consciousness than
his computation Dr Stuart hammeroff is a
professor of anesthesiology and
psychology at the University of Arizona
he's best known for his work on Quantum
Consciousness a theory he's co-created
with sir Roger Penrose does Neuroscience
need a revolution to understand
Consciousness and I believe it does it's
also a theory that's been highly
disputed by the scientific Community
does our brain really operate like a
supercomputer or is it actually more
like a Quantum Orchestra I think you
need microtubules and I think you need
these coherent vibrations tune in for
more about the true nature of
Consciousness welcome everybody to what
promises to be a wild tour through
Consciousness imagination and the human
brain a sample of which I brought here
for today's renowned guest my friend
second time appearance on the into the
impossible podcast it's Professor Dr
Stuart hammeroff the University of
Arizona where he is a professor of
anesthesiology and psychology and the
director of the center for Consciousness
studies where there were plans for the
last year because I get these emails
every year and I spoke many years ago at
this conference when it was last in San
Diego
and they just had a phenomenal
Conference held up in Encinitas I guess
um for the center for Consciousness
featuring our good old friend sir Roger
Penrose who's coming up on 93 I think
next week I think he just no you just
turned 93 yeah that's right Stuart how
are you very well Brian it's good to see
you again yeah I'm Glad You Came uh get
us get to escape the Heat and come into
the kitchen here in San Diego I'm what
you call a Zoni in this part of the
country so we do call you we see but you
usually leave around Labor Day so that's
nice uh so we get our we get our beaches
back I got the hint
not you personally we love having your
hair uh so you've been on before you
came on last time with sir Roger uh but
this time I wanted to get an in-depth
look into your research what drives you
passions and also to answer some
questions that I've had about
Consciousness for a very long time but I
thought first we'd do something that we
always do on this podcast we we do a
feature that we call judging books by
their covers you don't have a book today
that we're discussing but I thought we'd
look at the uh the cover of the
Symposium the artwork for the Symposium
and the last time I was here uh I spoke
at it in 2017 I can't believe it uh was
uh there was a brain riding a surfboard
somehow in La Jolla so anyway can you
explain the origin story and judge the
Symposium by its cover well the recent
Symposium uh was uh does Neuroscience
need a revolution to understand
Consciousness and I believe it does and
this particular conference which is kind
of a satellite conference of our usual
Consciousness conferences uh uh was a a
result of the last two a SSC conference
conferences which ascc is kind of the
other uh large uh uh conference annual
conference on Consciousness they tend to
be more conservative they are more
academic but they don't really deal with
Consciousness so much as cognition
metacognition language what Dave
Chalmers called the easy problems and uh
the last two ascc conferences have
featured theories of Consciousness but
didn't include ours even though they
were centered on the Templeton
Foundation adversarial collaboration
program which poured a lot of money into
Consciousness research and lasts for
years and originally there were five
theories uh integrated information
Theory Global neuronal workspace uh
predictive coding and higher order
Theory and ours orchestrated objective
reduction and the other four are really
what I call kind of wiring diagrams of
information flow in the brain without
really dealing with any biology they're
kind of you know information goes this
way it goes that way and then it all
converges and that's where Consciousness
is and so their their collaborations
were based on where is consciousness is
it in the front of the brain is in the
back of the brain there was one
particular one between IIT and Global
neuronal workspace on whether it's the
front of the brain in the back of the
brain and five million dollars later
they had a big showdown at the ASAC
conference and they couldn't decide it
was conflicting and uh and so it was a
big big tie and also uh Chalmers and
Christoph coke uh settled a bet from 25
years ago on whether there we'd have a
neural correlative Consciousness in 25
years Dave had said no because he
believes in the hard problem the
Consciousness is essentially unsolvable
and Chris said yes we'll have a neural
correlate in 25 well 25 years later
Kristoff had admit we we don't even
though he's a big advocate of uh IIT uh
he had to admit that that it wasn't
convincing anyway they didn't consider
our Theory and as I told Christoph and
Dave you know we've already shown that
Quantum effects and microtubules are
inhibited by anesthesia and therefore
the neural correlative Consciousness
should be in microtubules at a deeper
level within the brain but they only
consider neurons as simple on off
switches they only consider the
hodgkin-huxley 1950s era membrane-only
ion propagation signaling along the
membrane you know Touring that is a
computable algorithmic neuron and the
brain's not like that if you put
electrodes inside cortical pyramidal
cells they're non-algorithmic they have
some some other feature other than
membrane adjusting the threshold from B
to beat a great place for Consciousness
to come in and and adjust things and
modify what is otherwise
automatic Behavior so um because we
weren't part of the adversary we tried
to have an adversarial collaboration
with IIT and we had a meeting in early
2020 just before covid in 2 some with
Julio tanoni and Christoph kolk and
Roger and honor Bond and and other
colleagues of of mine of ours on the
orcor on the microtubule side but we
couldn't uh the idea in the adversary
collaboration was to have one one
experiment that if it went one way would
prove one theory if it went the other
would prove the other it'd be a decisive
experiment yes and we couldn't and we
couldn't uh come come up with anything
because number one I don't think IIT is
falsifiable and number two we're at a
deeper level and our Theory would be uh
it's talking about Quantum effects and
microtubules inside neurons faster
deeper Quantum and would be consistent
with any of the other theories which are
more like wiring diagrams or even
phrenology maps on the surface of the of
the skull so uh that kind of fell
through but Templeton generously gave us
two hundred thousand dollars to do two
experiments uh both of which turned out
very favorable to us one of which is
published and the other one uh will be
coming out soon when I had on David
charm Mars he graciously came on last
year for his new book and he's from
Australia and I asked him that the
following question which I want to ask
you if I were to have on AC DC the most
popular band besides maybe Olivia
Newton-John rest in peace from the land
down under of Australia and I were not
to ask them to play their song You Know
Back In Black I would be worth nothing
as a podcaster so I want to ask you uh
your greatest hit I asked him for his
greatest hit to find the hard problem of
Consciousness and and he did and that
was wonderful I want you and your words
to describe what is orc or okay as I
said most theories look at the brain as
a complex computer of simple neurons so
if you have complex enough interactions
and you're they're wired up in the
proper circuitry then Consciousness
emerges at a critical level of complex
interactions but but the neurons
themselves are simple on off switches no
different than what you would find in a
computer and functionally and this has
been the idea and this this grew out of
Hodgkin Huxley which lends itself very
well to uh algorithmic neurons uh by
biological and then computation and you
know the brain's Consciousness in the
brain has always been likened to the
current information processing
technology going back to the Greeks with
a seal ring and wax for memory and then
Telegraph switching circuits uh uh the
Hologram uh smoke signal well maybe not
smoke signals but uh and then uh the
computer of course the last uh 50 years
it's been the computer and AI has come
along and run with that idea and say
when we get complex enough or we get
enough this or that we'll have
Consciousness and I think that's
completely wrong because I follow
Roger's idea the Consciousness is
non-computational and there's something
other than computation something other
than a turing machine going on right so
with the orc or component of it relates
to quantum mechanics and
non-computability how how so if you look
at one neuron like as as I said if you
put an electrode into a pyramidal cell
which I think is the most likely place
on this in the cortex the layer five
pyramidal cells
um for reasons I could go into but uh
and you measure the membrane uh the the
kind of the input output you find that
the threshold for firing it's supposed
to be integration on the dendrites and
Soma to a threshold reach that that
triggers the firing and that's a one or
a zero and that lends itself to
computation and so it's all depend on
input versus output which is algorithmic
and touring however they found that
there were very there's a variability in
the threshold firing threshold on a B2B
basis on a firing to firing basis so
there was something other than than the
membrane or even a field coming in from
the outside because that would affect
the membrane let me just interject just
for clarification for my audience you
know because if I'm a little bit unclear
I'm sure that they might also be So when
you say that the threshold changes it
would be as if you have still zeros and
ones but the threshold to trigger in a
you know transistor-based computer it'd
be as if they're that threshold would
not be zero on five volts it would be
some intermediate value that itself
would change over time yes it changes on
a fire to firing basis and uh that was
uh they kind of everybody kind of
glossed over that well it's it's
artifact it's noise it's this it's that
but I it isn't and I mean uh and and
that is actually a perfect place for
Consciousness to come in because if
we're algorithmic if we're totally
computational then there's no
possibility of free will there's no
create uh creativity there's no
imagination it's all we're all basically
a computer not many people believe that
we have no Free Will and Sam Harris
Sabina hasenfelder many people believe
in super determinism and so I know
that's not a problem for them but I know
that but if you want to I actually I
don't believe that we don't have free
will and I've never met somebody I don't
know have you you might have you ever
met someone who acts in accordance with
a perspective that they have no free
will in other words Sam Harris I don't
think that he goes around thinking I I
have no free will so therefore I'm going
to act in accordance with that fact in
other words he sees it as a have you
ever encountered a patient perhaps that
uh maybe in psychological settings
I believe that like you know if they did
something wrong they cheated on their
wife that it's because of the big bang
you know is there something like that uh
well there could be but I think there's
a there's a bigger problem with free
will
which is that uh if you say something
and I say something in it and uh if if
we somebody looks at my brain at the
activity
recording or or processing what you said
I will have already responded to you yes
or a baseball player uh actually swings
the bat uh it doesn't really have enough
time to know where the the ball is and
uh going back to the experiments of
Benjamin libbit 1979 uh where he had
patients awake in surgery with their
brains exposed and could do
physiological tests uh there's he he
found that the brain refers information
backward in time and uh Roger wrote
about this in his book The Emperor's New
mind and I I then looked up a little bit
and studied him intensely and basically
Roger uh argues that every collapse
sends Quantum information both forward
and backward in time and Arona of says
the same thing and others do too so uh
backward time up it is allowable in
quantum physics up up to a point you do
have the grandfather causal Paradox
problem but but if if you you can get
around that or you can avoid it by just
not affecting anything that hasn't
collapsed yet so this backward time
effect actually enables you enables us
to act in in real time so even though
the activity process and what you said
hasn't happened yet it's going backward
in time so I can answer you consciously
but but the the phase space or the
parameter space isn't infinite in other
words if the baseball pitcher you know
throwing a pitch it's not going to you
know emerge from from The Dugout it's
going to emerge from his hand there's a
parameter space so that narrows down the
batter's ability to actually judge and
there is you know it's it's not that
it's a causal it's they're basing their
swing pattern uh on the actual you know
probability that they've witnessed over
thousands of pitches in the case of a
well that's that's the uh the mainstream
explanation and that may be true but uh
a guy named Robert Adair uh wrote a book
called the science of the Swing about
this and and it would argued against
that same thing with Cricket and tennis
and so forth and even rapid fire
conversation and there's a lot of
experimental evidence for it also
unfortunately if it's in the
parapsychology literature it gets
written off as exp as parasite apology
but there's a lot of precognition
there's some very mainstream studies
showing uh uh effects from the near
future right but getting back to the
actual orc or Theory so when we when we
talk about can you sum that up in a way
that you know a lay person can
understand it because I've had trouble I
know other physicists have trouble
understanding it
um and and I know you're not a physicist
but you've been intimately involved
you're the one person that Roger
responded to from the emperor's new mind
uh back which was the first book I ever
read as a science you know hungry kid
but but I want to ask you so the
orchestrated let's break it down what is
orc o r stand for and then what do each
one of those terms mean in Lay persons
terms please okay or is Roger's uh
theory for collapse of the wave function
to do due to general relativity or
quantum gravity however you want to
describe it I'll come to that in a
second orc is really what's happening in
the microtubules so let me put this in a
temperate perspective when I was in
medical school I was interested in the
brain mind problem Consciousness but
neurology a Neurosurgery Psychiatry
didn't really grab me as especially to
spend my life doing
I did a research elective in a cancer
lab was studying mitosis how cells
divide how these structures microtubules
mitotic spindles would grab the
chromosomes and they're all uh Tangled
Tangled Up and and mixed up and grabbed
them in perfect Pairs and separate them
to form the daughter cells so they had
to know where uh where to go what to do
there they needed to have some kind of
intelligence or possibly Consciousness
everybody else in the lab got fascinated
by the chromosomes and this was the dawn
of the genetic Revolution and they
probably made billions in genetic
engineering and so forth I got really
fascinated with how these structures
these microtubules knew where to go and
what to do I was interested in
Consciousness at that same time in the
early 70s it was discovered that the
microtubules were in all cells not just
mitotic spindles including neurons they
were chock full neurons were chock full
of them prior to that the fixative agent
had for electron microscopy been
dissolving them and I and the X-ray
diffraction crystallography of
microtubule came out from Amos and klug
in in the UK and it was a it was a like
a crystalline lattice of individual
proteins in a helical geometry with
Fibonacci geometry which I thought was
really interesting and uh and they were
in neurons and uh and they looked like
computers I was also learning about
computers for the first time about
Boolean switching matrices and I looked
at the structure of microtubule and a
Boolean switching I said you know they
look like computers maybe they're
processing information as little
computers and that's how they know where
to go and what to do and and organize
stuff inside the cells and so I
developed some theories and models and
worked with physicists at Los Alamos
Steen Rasmus and Jack josinski Stephen
Smith and others modeling microtubo says
automata like cellular automata each
protein subunit could be a one or a zero
interacting with its neighbors and we
showed that we could get propagating
patterns and information and they could
be pretty good computers especially if
you hook them up side by side in
opposite directions as we have inside
neurons inside dendrites so uh have
people built on is this a sign have they
built you know a squishy wet computers
using microtubules and not you know
maybe not human subjects but have they
they're smaller
uh honor bond has developed uh what he
calls brain jelly which is an organic
polymer that self-organizes in a helical
fashion which is based on microtubules
that he says is a quantum computer it's
an organic quantum computer room
temperature and that's he just got big
fun Big Time funding in India to develop
that but uh I'm getting ahead of myself
so I was going around the 70s and 80s to
neural net and AI meetings and where you
know
Curtis Wells talking about the
singularity we get to 10 to the 16th
operations per second they were looking
at the brain as 10 10 to the 11th
neurons uh a thousand synapses and about
100 Hertz gives you 10 to the 16th
operations per second so kurzuel
actually this came from Hans moravik in
the in the in the 80s I read his book uh
mine children I think and then kurzwa
picked it up and said well when we get
to that's the brain capacity 10 to the
16th operations per second when we get
there we'll have Consciousness in a
computer because he's coming on the
podcast next early next year so look
forward to sharing your ideas with them
okay and uh and I had calculated that
microtubules there were about a billion
tubulins switching in say 10 megahertz
gave you 10 to the 16th operations per
neuron so I was I was going on being a
real pain in the butt to them saying no
there's way way more information going
on and if you multiply the 10 to the
16th per neuron times the 10 to the 11th
neurons you get 10 to the 27th
operations per second so I I was moving
their goal post if they wanted to
believe me way way Downstream so they
didn't want to believe me they didn't
like that it made their you know because
they were saying give us a few more
billion and we'll have a conscious
computer and I say no no it's like 30 40
50 years in the future you know so they
said get out of here kid you bother me
you know and so uh anyway one day
somebody said okay wise guy let's say
you're right how would that explain
Consciousness and it was the hard
problem thrown in my face this is five
years before Dave uh Chalmers
discussed the hard problem other people
including John Searle had described it
in other ways I had to realize I had to
admit that this guy was right I didn't
have a mechanism for Consciousness you
know feelings love joy the color pink
the Blue Sky whatever taste smell of
coffee I had no idea it was these were
qualia and uh fortunately that person
recommended I read Roger's book uh the
emperor's new mind which I did and uh he
the first part of the book was arguing
against the idea that Consciousness is a
computation through girdle's theorem
that mathematical theorem can't prove
itself you have to have somebody outside
a conscious mathematician and he said
therefore for understanding you have to
be outside the computational system the
classical competition the touring
touring machine idea something outside
that and for that you had to leave
classical physics you had to go to
quantum physics and for that you had to
arrive at the at the single most um
mysterious issue in Quantum physic which
is the measurement problem a collapse of
the wave function and as you know in
quantum physics at small scales and
maybe large scales but at least the
small scales things can be in multiple
States or locations at the same time but
when measured or observed they seem to
collapse to one or the other now some
people say that doesn't happen in each
possibility branches off and forms its
own universe or decoherence does it some
people say that Consciousness causes
collapse none of those are really
satisfactory and in this book The
Emperor's New mind Roger came up with
his own new idea that there was a
self-collapse and to explain that he
brought in general relativity which is a
neat trick in and of itself because
quantum physics in general relativity
generally don't Jive but he likened the
position of a particle or a particle to
tiny curvatures in space-time now
Einstein had done it for big things like
the sun bending light behind the Stars
so that Eddington can see the stars
behind the Sun and that proved the
space-time curvature Roger did it for
tiny things so a tiny particle would
have a tiny curvature in space-time and
if it was in superposition of being here
and here it would have two curvatures it
would be a separation in underlying
space-time geometry and he used these
simple two-dimensional space-time sheets
to illustrate and you can imagine that
if the curvature is separated
indefinitely you'd have multiple worlds
but he's and you can imagine if somebody
looked at it and caused collapsed it
would go to one or the other without
explaining what the Consciousness was
out here but he said the separations
were unstable and after a Time T would
collapse to one or the other and when
that happened it would give a moment of
proto-conscious experience a qualia and
this was the only mechanism ever
proposed that I know of and still to
this day for a generation of qualia of
of Consciousness the wave function of
what because there's there's an infinite
number of uh systems in the that you
could describe right is it every
electron collapses their wave function
What wave function are we talking about
that yeah that's the beauty of it he
used space-time curvature so it doesn't
matter because any superposition of
anything would cut would be would be a
separation in in space-time geometry so
it in principle would work for any
superposition now to work in the brain
is another question but but it would
mean and it still means that there are
superpositions separating and collapsing
in the table in the air everywhere
ubiquitously throughout the Universe and
uh these collapses would be random uh
disconnected lack memory like me you
know that context and would be what uh
he calls uh and I call now
proto-conscious and this may seem
bizarre that these proto-conscious
events are happening everywhere but if
you're a pan psychist and many
neuroscientists have resorted to
pansychism because Neuroscience doesn't
work for Consciousness uh then you have
the issue that everything is conscious
including this fake brain including the
table so it's the same thing but then
you have the problem how do you combine
them into the kind of unified
Consciousness we have and you can't do
that for pan psychism but for Quantum
you can because of entanglement so and
this relies on yeah gravitational
effects which are far you know literally
40 orders of magnitude smaller than you
know special relativistic effects or
electromagnetic effects how do they
evade the decoherence time scales that
you know even in a simplistic many
worlds interpretation are happening 10
to the 30th times per second and how do
they persist long enough for us to have
that 100 Hertz which is one you know
hundredth of a second perception of
qualia or whatever else right well
everybody says the brain's too warm wet
and noisy for delicate Quantum effects
because you want to build a quantum
computer you go to the laboratory and do
it absolutely right we have a dilution
refrigerator so I'll take you down to
point zero zero one Kelvin right right
yeah for that purpose but the brain is
not uh and the brain is mostly water
however the brain is not homogeneous the
brain is not just one big slab with the
same amount of water everywhere the
brain is highly heterogeneous and
anesthesiologist is an im1 and
pharmacologists know that if you give a
molecule to a an organism if we give a
drug to a patient it will go in that in
that patient to where it dissolves to
where it's soluble and drugs have
different solubility so most drugs are
polar they're soluble in water and blood
and they go to charge receptors on
membrane surfaces but anesthetics which
are so Collective for erasing
Consciousness and have very very little
very little other effects on the brain
and uh they they go to nonpolar areas uh
fat like regions lipid-like regions
they're basically oil kind of like the
Benzene ring and oil and water don't mix
so in proteins all the the aromatic
rings of amino acids which is the basis
for organic chemistry and a key player
in in Quantum biology these organic
Rings uh coalesce inside proteins and so
we have these regions of nonpolar water
free because water oil and water don't
mix and they exclude water that support
quantum Optical effects and it's these
Quantum Optical effects which then
coupled to the nucleus to have enough
superposition movement and superposition
to reach threshold uh that gives you
Quantum effects uh in uh at Island
temperature and uh wets yes it's an
adiabatic system you have a Quantum
system a decoherence free Subs subsystem
inside a polar Shield more or less so
let's go back to the microtubules
themselves because you're an expert in
this field so microtubules exist in all
cells correct right but is there
anything different about their qualities
inside of the brain yes for one thing
they're more uh more variable
genetically there are 22 ISO isozymes
isoforms of tubulin in in the brain
you're only 11 in most other tissues and
then you can have uh post-translational
modifications uh perfect for memory uh
memory encoding so you can have a
roughly 30 different types of tubulin
and there's a billion per neuron in
these lattices and uh in the dendrites
and Soma the microtubules are they're
kind of permanently they're capped on
both ends so they don't add at one end
and lose with the other they don't have
what's called Dynamic instability where
they shatter and re-polymerize they
don't have to disassemble and get
involved in mitosis cell division which
they do in all other cells because
because
neurons don't divide once they're formed
they don't divide which means that the
neuron that the microtubules can stay in
their particular lattice configuration
and each one of those tubulins can be in
one of 30 so it's kind of a mosaic and
so that's a perfect mechanism for memory
which is and I think microtubules store
memory it can't be synapses because the
synaptic proteins only last hours to
days in memories last lifetimes and the
synapses are upregulated and done
regulated by microtubules and we've
shown how memory can be encoded from
synaptic events into the microtubules
and the dendritic microtubules are are
capped so they're stable over the
lifetime presumably the lifetime of
individuals and they don't have to
disassemble uh for for mitosis and in
dendrites and Soma they're in this very
strange mixed polarity Network so
microtubules of a plus end and a minor
set in all cells they're unipolar with
the uh beta Plus in my Alpha minus out
like spokes of a wheel and in an axon
they're also in unipolar in a a parallel
bundle in dendrites and Soma they're
broken interrupted
and they're part of the cytoskeleton so
if they're skeletal you wouldn't want to
break your femur and in half and have
one go it doesn't make any sense there
must be something else so you have one
going one way one the other and they're
in these mixed polarity networks which
uh which uh allow for recursive
processing and also interference beats
so if they're oscillating and say
megahertz and they're slightly different
energies because they're going to be in
the the external membrane is going to
affect them slightly differently they're
going to interfere and give slower beats
and that's how you get from say
megahertz uh
two kilohertz to Hertz to EEG in fact we
think EEG is generated by microtubule
oscillation interference can you explain
to me how anesthesia the conventional
model for how anesthesia actually works
the convention most people would say
anesthesia acts on membrane proteins
receptors Gaba receptors acetylcholine
receptors serotonin Glycine and maybe a
few others on the dendritic side however
uh not all anesthetics there's this
unitary feature of anesthesia if uh if
you uh if you rank them all in potency
that potency correlates perfectly with
their solubility in olive oil of all
things the aromatic nonpolar region of
like aromatic ranks like tryptophan
phenylalanine so if that holds over many
many orders of magnitude and uh and so
they all should act the same way but not
all anesthetics bind to all receptors
they don't all all bind to Gaba
receptors and there's never been any
studies showing a correlation between
anesthetic action on membrane receptors
and and potency and in fact the leader
in the the world leader in anesthetic
mechanism uh research a guy at UCSF
who's passed away now Ted eager yeah
when I was when I was uh in residency he
was the guy I mean and uh at UCSF and
the expert in anesthetic mechanism and
so forth and he and he uh he he and his
team worked to find which receptor or
receptors media anesthetic action and
after 20 years he gave up in 2008 he
wrote this paper and said that we need a
new paradigm this is not it's not member
receptors for one goes up one goes down
there's no unitary action and uh I told
him at the time I said you should look
at microtubules but uh he didn't want to
do that but uh since then Rod
eckenhoff's group at University of
Pennsylvania has been doing uh
systematic Research into anesthetic
mechanism and found for example 70
different proteins in a cell and a
neuron that bind anesthetics and about
half of the membrane half in the
cytoplasm cytoplasm including tubulin so
tubulin does bind uh uh anesthetics and
genomic and proteomic studies showed
that the gene expression changed the
most for tubulin suggesting that's the
functional effect and they also did
optogenetics where they had a
fluorescent anesthetic that only uh only
acted as an anesthetic when you hit it
with UV light and they gave it to these
tadpoles and uh they swam around and
fortunately tadpoles have transparent
heads so they can then illuminate with
with ultraviolet light and when they did
that they all went belly up the
anesthetic became active and they
donated their little brains to science
and they found that the anesthetic was
bound to tubular microtubules and also
people on the the drug texol which
stabilizes microtubules it's an
anti-cancer drugs so the the they can't
disassemble uh for mitosis uh require
more anesthesia that also came out of uh
eckenhoff's lab so there's
circumstantial uh evidence it's not uh I
think there's far more for a
microtubules than anything else despite
that the party line is still membrane
receptors and how does it relate to say
a drug you know a uh you know
barbiturate or some sort of a depressant
or something like how does anesthesia
which you I don't know phenobarbital
what do you what's the most common one
that uh
so how does that relate to say you know
a classic you know schedule one narcotic
are they related at all well narcotics
act that opiate receptors primarily
however if you give enough
fentanyl for example uh you get a
general anesthetic but they're really uh
they're really supposedly specific for
opiate receptors propofol and the
anesthetics follow the Meyer Overton
correlation and therefore they should
have a common uh a common mode of Action
Now propofol does bind to Gaba receptors
and everybody as well they act on gab
receptors but they also get inside the
cell in fact it was recently shown that
that psychedelics also act inside the
cell that there are five ht2a receptors
inside the neuron in the microtubule
Associated protein so it it's it's
likely that psychedelics act inside
neurons directly on more directly on
microtubules as do anesthetics
interesting and there's some quantum
physics or say related to things like
spintronics or the ising model things
like that what's sort of the work in the
physical quote-unquote hard Sciences
that's been most you know provocative to
you in an interesting way
I actually worked with Isaac models and
and uh microtubules as icing models are
cellular automata molecular automata
where each tubulin was a uh could be a
single single state but I think that's
that's too simplistic and I think
probably the most significant work has
been done by my friend honor Bond
banyapad who works at the National
Institute of materials Sciences In Scuba
Japan who started working on
microtubules in around 2009 after
reading uh uh some of our papers and uh
he he started out studying he's a
nanotechnologist to begin with and he
started out studying individual
microtubules with four electrodes two to
record and two to stimulate and if you
stimulate a microtubule
um let's say with a DC Uh current a DC
voltage or a voltage it's a good
insulator however if you uh put a
current on an ultra alternating at
different frequencies AC curve and sweep
the sweep the frequencies you'll find
certain frequency bands where the
microtubule becomes highly conductive
almost uh almost superconductive he
calls it ballistic conducted and this
happens every three orders of magnitude
in uh in in hertz kilohertz megahertz
gigahertz and terahertz and and each in
each level the the conductance band is a
it's what he calls A Triplet of triplets
there's three Peaks and each Peak has
three Peaks and this triplet of triplet
repeats and kilohertz megahertz
gigahertz and terahertz and so it's kind
of like a resonant Orchestra or
something in one you know microtubes
themselves are these uh uh incredible
Quantum vibrational devices basically
based on KT you don't have to pump them
you don't have to give them energy it's
just they take Ambient Energy and
vibrate in these frequencies so he
discovered that and I'm really itching
to see anesthetical facts and we're
discussing doing uh building a a gas a
chamber where we can have airtight
control and and study quantum effects
microtubules with effects of anesthesia
so uh he did that and then in a couple
years ago he studied a neural network
and and with these uh dielectric
resonance probes inside the neurons in
the network and found uh gigahertz he
can measure gigahertz and megahertz
oscillations in the dendrites and Soma
that controlled the firing more so than
the membrane potential so here was a
perfect example of uh the microtubules
overriding membrane effects which is
exactly what you want for Consciousness
to overcome automatic Behavior so you're
driving down the road and you're
daydreaming or mind wandering and then
somebody stores in front of you your
Consciousness takes over and uh it's not
coming from outside because you wouldn't
you would see it in the membrane
potential so it must be coming from
inside or it's likely to be coming from
inside and this would explain exactly in
fact he's demonstrated that and then
more recently he's been able to detect
megahertz and gigahertz from the scalp
with a single electrode and now an array
and he calls this the ddg the dodecagram
uh which is essentially ultra high
frequency EEG where you can measure at
least megahertz and gigahertz from the
scale and we did some some fooling
around with that uh while he was here he
brought a device and showed uh uh
triplet of triplets from my head and
others and uh and we tried it on a dog
and we got it we got a megahertz Peak we
tried it on a on an apple and did not
see anything and we tried it on a plant
and actually at right where the stem and
the root combined we saw some megahertz
activity so Mike uh plants have have
microtubules I think you know uh plants
are are could be conscious at a very low
frequency so you know I think we have
for example 10 million orcowar moments
per second
and uh that interferes down to give EEG
and cognition so forth whereas a a plant
might have a couple per minute so it
could be at the base level you know
people argue as much about you know what
is consciousness as they do about what
is life right so it could be that you
know only living things are conscious if
uh you know no I I don't mean currently
alive but those that have capability to
be alive you have a an apple maybe it's
cut off from you know actual you know
cellular mitosis and so forth but um but
you know the pan psychic notion should
have a restriction on it in my opinion I
I don't support pan psychism myself but
uh but but as as intriguing possibility
allows people to kind of get around some
various conundrum I want to ask you um
about two two relevant things that have
been really popular topics for me and
very interesting for me to study lately
uh one has to do with artificial
intelligence
and natural stupidity uh but the other
one has to do with brain organoids so we
had our good friend uh Professor Allison
motrion early this year actually he was
our first in studio guest we'll put a
link to that up somewhere over here uh
in the new studio here at UC San Diego
and uh and he devised you know the
detailed many great developments that
are going on brain organized and so
forth like what are the kind of base
level Primitives that you could distill
you know a brain to Consciousness to is
it like an organoid I mean what would be
the ideal you know control and variable
kind of setup for a classic decisive
experiment in this field well I've been
discussing this actually and Allison and
I wrote a paper on on uh trying to
detect look for Consciousness in brain
organoids and I thought it was pretty
good paper actually and the the main
feature was that he's he sees uh
rhythmic uh rhythmic Dynamics at
different frequencies and they're face
coupled kind of like uh kind of like the
megahertz gigahertz activity the
different scales but it wasn't that much
of a difference in in frequency and uh
so uh
one idea was whether they were coupled
or not and I I would think that if they
were if the organ I was conscious there
would be uncoupling of the phase because
if if you're just everything's in phase
and you're on automatic pilot and you're
you're unconscious whereas uh I think
you want to uh you want to decouple and
and that's where Consciousness could
come in so that's one of the things we
put in that paper and uh my friend uh
Hartman Nevin at Google and his uh
friends at uh UC Santa Barbara are
trying to uh entangle an organoid with
the quantum system and uh so that'll be
interesting I personally think that uh
it's the organizer is already too
complicated they should try to entangle
microtubules and in fact honor bond has
shown entanglement between two
microtubules interesting so that is the
Primitive base level that could be the
most useful sort of uh building block
Lego for studying Consciousness in some
sense I think uh for the I think you
need microtubules and uh I think you
need these coherent vibrations megahertz
gigahertz and uh you know with this uh
device we're measuring megahertz and I
think at this point in time that
megahertz uh uh from the brain is
probably as good
a candidate for a neural correlative
Consciousness as there is because we can
measure it you know from our little
studies it was it was reproducible uh
animals have it plants seem to have it
uh inanimate objects do not have it and
uh and we also tried stimulating with uh
transcranial ultrasound and uh we found
uh on one side and measured from the
other and we found after a slight delay
an increase in activity so uh and
transcran ultrasizes mechanical
vibrations in megahertz uh which does
cause mental effects after a slight
delay you get a a kind of a euphoric
mood enhancement and a number of people
have been studying that what about the
electromagnetic phenomena The Havana
syndrome things like that are there
pertinent aspects that we could learn
about Consciousness either from the
claimed or real uh evidence that's been
presented for electromagnetic
stimulation I would bet that Havana
syndrome is some kind of effect on
microtubules it could be microwave
gigahertz we know microtypo's resonated
gigahertz it might be radio waves
megahertz
but if you if you over resonate
something like the bridge you know that
over over it's gonna it's gonna shatter
and I think that's exactly what happened
and in fact concussion uh concussion is
in concussion your microtubules get get
fractured and broken and that's been
well proven and uh so it's it's a lot
like a post-concussion syndrome
interesting uh last thing before we take
uh audience questions
um has to do with these you know human
brain computational augmentation systems
things like neuralink and so forth I'd
like to get your uh impression of those
what what are the prospects we've we've
had uh Noam Chomsky on a long time ago
talked about his pessimism that this is
uh not really pertinent to how
Consciousness is really organized or
presented uh what are your thoughts as a
as a someone who's deeper in this field
than gnome certainly is
if you're talking about uh bring
computer interface interface with uh EEG
forget it uh the EEG is way too crude
it's way uh you know uh anything's going
to be washed out uh you might have a
better better chance with this megahertz
and uh you know which I think is going
to convey a lot more uh information and
also has the advantage of uh uh uh this
guy at the conference Patrick palucky
pointed out that uh that the a big
problem with uh brand computer interface
with EEG is that blink artifact or
facial movement it screws it all up and
we showed in with our megahertz device
that you can blink all you want and you
can make faces and it doesn't change one
bit so it would be better for that uh
aspect and also you get way more
information absolutely so we have a
large number of questions from Twitter
and from I didn't get to answer about AI
oh yeah you say one thing yeah I was
gonna yeah let's go uh there's a guy
Brian romelly uh you know I've seen him
on Twitter and he's been on James also
so he asked chat GPT how what's the most
likely way for you to become conscious
and chat GPT said the best way no I
won't I won't
use your Hal voice he's your Hal voices
said the the best way is through Penrose
hamroth Orco Arthur and went on with a
pretty nice exposition of the of the
theory really uh but let's let's talk
about AI generally uh not just uh you
know the the chat chat Bots and stuff we
have a bribot by the way she can find my
website you can interact with me and ask
me your questions uh as Brian the other
Brian did but um tell me Stuart what do
you think is uh sort of the the promise
the pitfalls The Perils of this kind of
Singularity of AI that seems to be upon
us or will be imminently so I don't
think AI is going to become conscious
they may try to convince us it's
conscious
but uh if it's just computation I don't
think so you know maybe if somebody
builds a quantum computer with objective
reduction possible but just more
complexity more this more than it's no
it's not going to be it may you know it
may fool some people but I don't think
it's be conscious it could still be
dangerous but
um not not because of its conscious I
still think it's uh interesting to get
your impression about this what you know
Consciousness if we were to understand
it it would it would certainly involve
things we can't really anticipate right
now in terms of understanding who we are
what we are but it's kind of like
cosmology another cos thing uh which is
uh which is that it's incredibly
significant but it may not be important
in other words like it won't affect our
daily lives and Technology maybe
Consciousness would I want to get your
impression about that but on the other
hand it's clearer anesthesiology I mean
anesthesiology might be one of the most
important inventions of all time right
and so along with you know I I wrote a
chapter in 2000 uh this guy wrote a book
The Greatest inventions of the past 2000
years and I wrote The Judge around
anesthesia so we always have these you
know revisionist histories where people
say you know if only our live and you
know in the 1640s and and I would have
just cleaned up I would have had all the
treasure and women but if you broke your
leg you know we live better now than not
even just like 400 years ago we live
better than like the Queen of England
lived in the 1950s or 40s uh it's just
it's just uh unbelievable so in terms of
benefit to humanity as Alfred Nobel you
know clearly wanted and what would what
would create sort of a a bigger impact
understanding Consciousness the base
layer of reality as we perceive it and
there are as many different
interpretations of quantum chaotics as
there are interpretations of
Consciousness
Donald Hoffman you know we've had them
all on
um and no one can tell me what it's like
to be a bat uh yet but I want to ask you
which would have a bigger breakthrough
the advances in anesthesiology and brain
computer interfaces and being able to
control the brain versus understanding
what Consciousness is
I think under well it depends what it
turns out to be if we're right and
Consciousness is an intrinsic feature of
the universe uh connecting us through
multiple layers down to the fundamental
space-time geometry that would kind of
Define our place in the universe and I
think that would be important for uh not
just practical reasons medical reasons
but also spiritual reasons philosophical
reasons we would be connected uh it
would kind of change our outlook on the
other hand if it turns out if it goes
the other way and it's a emergent
epiphenomenal process then who cares so
we've now reached the point in the
conversation where I'd like to ask some
questions from the audience so my friend
Dr Leonard Mo many uh who's a great
scholar and friend of the show he asks
you the following question he asks what
are your thoughts on Compton making
connections between Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle and Free Will the
uncertainty principle is the basis for
the orcor collapse so Rogers oh are
collapsed it's t equals H bar over e sub
G so the larger the superposition the
faster it will collapse and it's it's an
average so there's still some
uncertainty it's got like a radioactive
decay and that's what give gives you uh
Consciousness uh and and Action for free
will but as I mentioned before uh
generally the brain activity is is too
late so without uh backward time
referral you don't have the even the
possibility for real-time conscious
action and Consciousness would therefore
be epi phenomenal and we have a false
illusion which most people think are the
the the party line in neuroscience and
philosophy starting from Dan Dennett and
uh uh Dan Wagner's book uh the illusion
of free will is that uh free wills is an
illusion because the activity happens
too late and our non-conscious autopilot
acts first although they never explain
where the brain activity is for the
non-conscious autopilot because that
should have some activity too and uh and
then we have this false illusion after
the fact that we were in control
Consciousness and illusion and uh the
backward time effect rescues the
possibility rescues conscious Free Will
Brad Caldwell on Twitter and reminder
you can always ask questions of all my
guests on Twitter at Dr Brian Katie and
YouTube Dr Brian Katie Instagram Dr Mary
uh Brad Caldwell asked the following
about the Triple Peak significance are
there any noticeable changes in such
patterns during different conscious
phases like sleep versus anesthetics
versus yeah we don't know yet uh the
first thing I want to do is anesthesia I
I suspect that the the megahertz uh
triplets I hope will be more sensitive
to Anesthesia than EEG if you if you
look at EG gamma tends to go away and
everything kind of slows down so it will
be interesting to see what happens to
the megahertz and gigahertz with
anesthesia and also perhaps with with
psychedelics I bet they go up I've got a
lot of very brilliant people in my
audience the next one is s case villain
K who asks or aside which what theory
would you put your money on as a second
best guess
I like recurrent processing uh
predictive coding because it's uh it's
not uh it's more than just a wiring
diagram it's a process that can happen
at multiple levels in fact uh recurrent
processing happens as I said you have
microtubules in opposite directions so
information can go here and then here so
we did a paper 1990 with with two
microtubules in opposite direction
showing uh learning between these two
microtubules so I think recurrent
processing and predictive coding is a
fundamental process not just at the
neural level but all the way down
including microtubules so that's my
second favorite great John Hussein
Kennedy asks are there any aromatic ring
structures that are non-carbon that
could share the quantum properties of
benzene such as six silicon ring hexa
Benzene it would have to have Pi
resonance and the the indole ring in
tryptophan and a lot of the Psychedelic
and serotonin a lot of the psychedelics
has a nitrogen in the in the five ring
and so it doesn't have to be all carbon
but it has to allow a pie resonance uh
orbital Robbie is asking specifically
I'm very interested in researching the
properties of microtubules especially as
wave guides ordered water very
interesting question the the water
inside so water on any ordered surface
is is going to be ordered in other words
it's not going to be just random water
it's going to align with the charges and
the microtubules have a lot of charges
and on the outside and also inside and
on the inside the water channel uh
actually honor but I was talking about
this yesterday the the water channel is
uh is in was he saying terahertz it's
oscillating coherently in terahertz and
in fact uh before I started working with
Roger in the 90s I wrote a paper with
Quantum physicists from Japan uh Amari
jibu and kunio yasui and Carl Friedman
was on that and Scott Hagan about uh
super Radiance in the water Channel
inside microtubules and uh uh I I
thought originally the microt juice
might be a wave guys for
electromagnetics but it's kind of high
energy because the wavelength would be
small however the centrioles are cilia
which are not which are uh nine triplets
uh of of microtubules it's about 150
nanometers in diameter and that's a
perfect Optical wave guide and in fact
uh Albrecht Bueller has shown that uh
centrioles which are essentially cilia
to cilia detect photons and uh and and
capture them and there's the silly in
every one of our rod and Cone cells and
photons pass through them to get the
rhodopsin in the back and I was talking
to somebody at the conference who agreed
with me that it's likely that the silly
it might be extracting Quantum and
information and sending them through the
mouth and there's Mueller cells into the
brain other than the optic nerve so we
may be detecting more than quite
literally meets the eye Quantum
optically very good okay so next
question uh comes from atai bark hey who
asks your thoughts on Matthew Fisher
Posner molecule proposal where quantum
entanglement occurs in the brain but not
via microtubules
well first of all uh there's no Posner
cluster clusters in the brain uh as far
as I can tell poster clusters are
calcium phosphate crystals that might
happen in bone formation
but not anything cognitive not anything
information so they're not I don't see
how they'd be very useful to store
information if you want a lattice the
microtubos are perfect the other thing
the other problem with that is that
lithium the Isotopes of lithium differ
in their Mass significantly and so
you're not sure if the difference in
isotope is due to the the spin or the or
the mass now there is a very interesting
isotope effect in Consciousness which is
Xenon Xenon is an anesthetic it's a
single atom inert uh atom and it's and
uh complete outer shells so it's
nonpolar and it's a perfectly good
anesthetic and follows Meyer Overton
anyway it can have different isozymes
and a a group in China Study the potency
of the different isozymes and they found
the one uh the one isozyme that had a
spin one half was significantly less
potent than the other and they pass
postulated that the spin one half
actually promoted Consciousness that
actually accelerated Consciousness and
therefore the Xenon was antagonizing its
own anesthetic effect and I reviewed
that paper for anesthesiology and they
asked me to write a uh an editorial
which I did and so I elucidated exactly
how the spin one-half might might
interact with the other Quantum stuff
going on in the brain wow okay Tom
Anderson Is frequent uh fan of the uh
podcast uh asked the following questions
or evidence for Consciousness extending
outside of the brain say in the entirety
of the nervous system
well as I said there's
proto-consciousness everywhere but I
think he might be referring to auto body
experiences or near-death experiences or
even afterlife
and uh I'm asked that question quite
often and uh in my you know if
Consciousness is happening in space-time
geometry it's conceivable that it could
when the blood stops flowing in the and
the oxygen stuff's been delivered that
the quantum information might dissipate
to the universe at large but remain
entangled as something like a Quantum
Soul now I don't suggest any evidence
for that I don't I I won't disbelieve it
I I think it may be true but I'm not
claiming that I'm just claiming that
it's not impossible and that anybody who
says that it's absolutely impossible
it's unscientific
until they show exactly what
Consciousness is that's they can't they
can't make that claim if Consciousness
is non-local and a Quantum effect uh
connects to the fundamental space-time
geometry then things like auto body near
death and uh afterlife are not
impossible no very good and I mean
there's so much you know just wide open
you know Blue Sky stuff that we could
talk about I mean I'm thinking as you're
talking uh you know there's a whole
subset there's a gentleman named mogadot
who I'd like to get on the podcast he
worked at Google X and tragically lost
his son very early and his uh son's life
and he dedicated his life to making the
world happier place and he's got this
mission called one billion happy so you
know mo if you're out there I'd love to
have you on
um but one of the things he talks about
is you know the improbability of things
that we take is mundane even
Consciousness and I was thinking you
know what if uh if if any of these
models are true it could be the
Consciousness lasts I mean certainly
microtubules are dividing a second after
a person dies right or whatever that
means brain Dead versus heart dead we
could discuss that there's still
processes happening if it's happening in
a plant that's attached to the ground
you know by the time causality takes it
takes quite a bit of time for the
message to get to the toenail that
you've stopped being alive right so
could you extend this and give hope to
people of Wall Street that's where some
of the danger lies though right because
people project anything they want onto
these I mean some of the questions I
didn't ask are really out there
um you know and it's uh Curious to me
how you navigate this realm you know of
scientific scientific approach and using
it as a discipline that's falsifiable
potentially in the paparian sense uh
that's you know uh the bio
neurobiological obviously but then you
mentioned parapsychology and a spoon
bending and stuff no you didn't mention
it no you would never do it but but you
did you did mention parapsychology so
the question is you know how do you how
does a serious scientist you know kind
of navigate these very fraught Shoals of
you know kind of non-seudoscientists
where you know Quantum healing can cure
cancer or whatever versus doing a
rigorous hardcore science that you're
known for how do you well you're putting
a few words in my mouth but but I did I
I do believe that it's possible after
life is possible I don't Advocate that
it's true I don't know
um but until we know what Consciousness
is we can't say that it doesn't exist
and uh if it's a non-local Quantum
effect then then it's possible but the
reason I can even talk about that is
that I don't I don't depend on grants
you know pleasing anybody who has their
own preconceived notions uh I I know
I've run a foul of AI people I've run a
foul of a lot of uh funding uh agencies
who I think have ulterior motives and
eight and their own agendas whether they
admit it or not but I you know I've
always made my living as an
anesthesiologist and uh and I this has
been my I won't say my hobby but my
passion and my research and uh figure
out anesthesia figuring out
Consciousness and so I've been able to
follow my nose and say what I I think
whether it's whether it's going to cut
off funding or not that because I don't
really depend on funding yeah so and
then and Roger is the same way I mean he
just says what he you know logically
thinks yeah no I know you guys are
courageous and last time I asked you
when you're on the podcast I asked you
uh for the advice to your former self
which is my way of of bringing back to
the podcast the name originally given to
us by uh Sir Arthur C Clarke who said
the following he said that uh the only
way to know the limits of the possible
is to go beyond them into the impossible
so ITI and I asked you that in the form
of advice to your former self what would
you give your advice to your former self
as 20 year old man to give yourself the
courage to do what you've done have this
courageous career so you answer that
question now I'm going to ask you
another question uh that's another quip
of the great Sir Arthur C Clarke and he
said that um when an elderly not calling
you elderly you're older than me you're
gonna retire you're Emeritus but
um when an elderly but distinguished you
aren't distinguished scientists says
something is possible he or she is very
likely to be right but when he or she
says something is impossible they are
very likely to be wrong I want to ask
you uh Stewart Professor hammeroff what
have you changed your mind about what
have you been wrong about say in the
modern you know incarnation of your
career not before you met sir Roger and
in this field of Consciousness research
studies what have you been wrong about
if anything I don't know can I get back
to you I don't want to sound arrogant
but I but you know the major things like
microtubules and Quantum and people you
know particularly lately of trying to
say well you know you get a great model
of quantum coherence and microtubes you
don't need objective reduction you know
quantum gravity even you kind of sneered
at it and the energy is so low Roger had
a good explanation for that and uh I
just think that it's it's it's logical
it makes sense to me the numbers seem to
work and uh it's the only uh proposal
for for Claudia for Consciousness ever
ever put forth so I think I was right
latching onto microtubules as the key to
Consciousness and I think I was right in
agreeing with Roger and I think he was
right in agreeing with me very nice well
Stewart hammeroff Professor hammeroff
University of Arizona azoney
self-declared Sony uh Zoni zombie no no
you're not a zombie uh thank you so much
for coming back on the into the
impossible podcast for your second
appearance I hope that you'll come back
again for a third fourth fifth in the
future whenever you come to uh Southern
California you're always welcome and we
always uh learn so much from you and
broaden our Horizons uh and uh and take
us on a tour of the inner Cosmos the
cosmos between our ears as we study I
like this yeah the inner Cosmic feel
free to use it you use the Astro
Consciousness right so yes
very good well thank you so much thank
you Brian